vous avez régulation géraldine très mais
quand vous êtes sur un ring et que vous
donnez des coups vous en prenez aussi un
peu est ce que vous entendez la clameur
est ce que vous entendez des gens qui
vous qui se compte votre nom j'entends
un brouhaha rhin jamais ça c'est les
motards
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore défaits tony bas je me focalise
sur une deux voies moi je j'entends mon
coach et donc en fait on le travaille à
l'entraînement ça par exemple défend on
va s'entraîner avec la musique on va
monter la musique à fond et ton coach va
te donner des conseils
faut que tu puisses être même de
l'écouté parce qu'il ya une telle
ferveur cryptée le côté c'est pas le
tennis ça c'est sûr imaginerait dégâts
[Rires]
avec sa belle gueule pourquoi vous
mettez pas de protection mais non mais
on n'est pas dessus de la mer tu crois
quoi le gaillard est attendu mais je
vais pas cacher des screens
[Applaudissements]